for weeks he's warned of sanctions now
faced with what he sees as russian
aggression in ukraine joe biden has
acted
we're implementing full blocking
sanctions
on two large russian financial
institutions
veb
and their military bank we're
implementing comprehensive sanctions on
russian sovereign debt
that means we've cut off russia's
government
from western financing we'll also impose
sanctions on russia's elites and their
family members they share in the corrupt
gains of the kremlin policies and should
sharon the pain as well the president
has spent a lot of time with his
national security team over the last 48
hours they insist they've covered all
possible moves from moscow and the next
step by vladimir putin will dictate
further u.s reaction
biden still hopes for a diplomatic
solution but there was a warning to the
american public an extended crisis might
hit them in the pocket
defending freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that
one expert says it makes sense that
biden hasn't thrown everything at russia
this early leaving a diplomatic off-ramp
they need to keep you know part of their
powder dry
to see what his next move is this this
gross violation
further violation of ukrainian
territorial integrity
uh there has to be a a cost for that
the ukrainian foreign minister has been
in washington part of the international
merigo round of top-level talks he's
been meeting defense secretary lloyd
austin at the pentagon he says the
russians have tried to split the west
with their actions something that has
failed and i've never seen nato
more united and more resolute
standing firm is one alliance in support
of ukraine's right to defend its
sovereign territory it's two years since
then candidate biden tweeted out that
vladimir putin would be reluctant to
take any aggressive action if he was
president because he's gone toe to toe
with him in the past he touted his
foreign policy experience he's going to
need all that experience if he's to
reach a diplomatic solution to what is a
growing military crisis alan fisher al
jazeera at the white house